this
can be scary and rightfully so
sharks have patrolled the waters for
over 400 million years
and while they are powerful creatures
our stories have given them the
reputation
of being vengeful killers
hollywood says so you're gonna need a
bigger quote so does the media a life or
death struggle with one of the ocean's
most dangerous predators
but are sharks really the human hunters
terror
of all men who enter the ocean or the
hunted
well it's going to be a beautiful sunny
day today you might want to do some of
those outdoor activities
i think the reason that sharks are
feared by the general public is
pretty self-explanatory they freaking
bite people sometimes
this is jess cramp nat geo explorer and
founder of sharks pacific
she also lives near a lot of roosters so
you might hear this
but back to the shark bites it's
unfortunate that it happens but it does
happen so trying to avoid that fact i
feel like is a bit futile at this stage
these rare bites typically stem from
curiosity
or mistaken identity yet how we feel
about
sharks versus the data that's a
different story
like a really different story
we think all sharks look like this and
do this
but actually sharks are an incredibly
diverse group of fish
some sharks live most of their lives in
a really small radius just within a few
coral heads and others will swim around
the planet
they range from whale sharks which are
the largest shark species and they get
to be
about 40 feet long down to the dwarf
lantern shark which is about
8 inches that's cool but when did they
become the bad guys
let's ask one of the people behind the
international shark attack file
george burgess as long as humans entered
the sea
or floated upon it the inevitable
conflict between humans and sharks was
present
from the greeks romans and spanish
explorers tales were written
about battles with sharks but fast
forward
to when leisure time became a thing an
american started going to beaches
the shark attacks from those ancient
tales they weren't really happening
it became obvious that shark attack
certainly wasn't as common as
people were saying it was so the
pendulum had swung
from one side to the other and this
millionaire
was so convinced shark attacks weren't a
thing
he offered a 500 reward to anyone who
could prove him wrong
wild dude as in would jump into the
water with a real shark at parties wild
yeah also many scientists at the time
agreed
until this happened when 1916 came
around and there was a series of attacks
that occurred on the new jersey
coastline suddenly
the real world slapped everybody across
the face
starting on july 1st and spanning two
weeks time
the coastline of new jersey witnessed
five shark attacks
resulting in four deaths people were
spooked
locals even attempted to fight back by
throwing dynamite into the water
seriously because the new jersey
coastline was a popular vacation place
for the elite
including the president there was
immediate concern in action that we had
to get this taken care of because
i got a vacation already planned later
this summer
the white house agreed to give federal
aid to drive away
all the ferocious man-eating sharks
which have been making prey of bathers
eventually they put the blame on an
eight-foot juvenile great white
but by then it was front page news the
damage
was done while 1916
played its role on shark's reputation it
was a fictional story that really did a
number
yep you guessed it the book in the movie
jaws
as in any good cinema or any good book
if you can get the reader or the viewer
fully immersed then you've done your job
[Music]
consider the audience immersed the novel
by peter benchley spent 44 weeks as a
best seller
and the movie became the largest
grossing film at the time
it essentially created the summer
blockbuster people believed
every last bit of that is fact even
though
it took great liberties with facts some
knowingly
and some just because we know more now
than what we knew then
[Music]
one such belief was that sharks are
vengeful human hunters
which in turn led to a surge in humans
hunting them
shortly after the movie came out there
was a great influx in shark fishing
tournaments up and down the east coast
the united states
as a result shark population began
decline
today scientists estimate a staggering
100 million
sharks are killed every year around the
world
and to make matters worse sharks are
especially vulnerable because they take
longer to mature
and typically produce their young at a
slower rate
so sharks are in trouble while habitat
destruction
pollution and climate change are
definitely problems for sharks
our biggest impact is through fisheries
overfishing of sharks is predominantly
led by the demand for their fins
meat and liver oil and the lack of
management to ensure
shark fisheries are sustainable the way
that we can make the most impact for
sharks is actually through working with
fishing agencies with fishermen
also spatial protections on important
critical habitat for them
to try to reduce mortality and create a
few more safe havens where they can
actually
hang out and repopulate
the common narrative of sharks will
likely continue to be
on rare attacks but in reality the
species are in need
even peter benchley came to this truth
as he later focused his efforts
on shark conservation if there's one
thing i know for dead certain it's that
i couldn't possibly write jaws today
i could not turn this beautiful beast
into a villain
shark conservation is not a one size
fits all it's a multi-pronged problem
but they are fixable and that's the one
thing that i think is really important
for people to know is that
these are problems that while we may
have created them they
are fixable
[Music]
you